nous vous parlions hier des taux
d'incidence de lakovic 19 dans nos deux
départements des chiffres qui augmente
chaque jour dans le sud nos choix
ce taux bat des records 300 93,40 pour
cent mille habitants
c'est à dire plus élevé que le taux
départemental une campagne de dépistage
a donc été lancé depuis lundi dans
différentes communes pourtant le
calendrier des rendez-vous a du mal à se
remplir
la faute à un manque d'information ou un
manque d'intérêt
reportage à tauxigny symbole d'hélène
chapelet francis à 64 ans il a déjà reçu
une dose du vaccin astrazeneca il ya un
mois mais aujourd'hui il vient se faire
dépister pour la première fois un de ses
proches est positif au coronavirus alors
il préfère en avoir le coeur net
dans ce centre de dépistage éphémère
installée pour la journée à tauxigny
symbole il aura la réponse en 15 minutes
grâce à ce test antigénique réalisé par
le personnel de la croix rouge
comme j'ai eu un contact avec quelqu'un
qui a eu copie qu'il a pris hier ou
avant-hier et que
dire par précaution j'ai préféré venir
on s'est vus à l'extérieur à se pâmer
intérieure mais promet toujours être
prudent de façon à le donner à quelqu'un
de sa famille quoi ou de les amis depuis
le mois de février cette équipe composée
de 6 personnes intervient en entreprise
ou dans les petites communes sur demande
de la rs l'idée c'est de rapprocher le
dépistage des territoires ruraux et
désengorger ainsi les centres permanents
de tours où logent aller à loches sa
demande effectivement un déplacement que
les gens n'ont pas forcément le temps
l'envi et que le centre de loches est
extrêmement chargé
ce qui se conçoit d'ailleurs donc la
tente est parfois longue
alors que dans un centre proche
les gens connaissent les lieux ça enlève
aussi une part de stress on essaie soit
malgré un dispositif efficace mise en
place la salle d'attentes ce n'a pas été
d'une grande utilité
deux heures avant la fermeture 35
personnes seulement étaient venus se
faire tester prochain dépistage gratuit
vendredi à la salle des fêtes de
preuilly sur claise de 10h à 18h